all right now as requested let's have a
look at an example where I'm somewhere
else so let's convert rather than this
guy let's convert okay now you help me
out right if you want let's do one where
it's like just a brand new because you
will get norm exact values okay so you
give me a complex number it's gonna be
the third quadrant just give me a
complex number
any complex I'll be like negative five
that's it there cancel s minus 3i okay
fine well aware of all right so you can
see I've gone channel to the left and
I've gone down third quadrant so far so
good so how do I convert this thing if
you someone who said for who was the
person who said for some take more okay
he was he was trying to help us out to
at least make not all the numbers versus
because you just actually it's still not
gonna be done if I twelve would do it
twelve would do it okay
I wonder well where am I gonna go next
I'm gonna good Pythagoras right I'm
gonna go to Paris so the two sets of
common values you'll find are either
once that gives you nice arguments this
will give you a nice argument like so or
ones that give you a nice modulus right
which there are a hold on you you'll
never really get both really unless
you've got like an isosceles triangle
anyway let's have a go shall we uh we
will do the bunch others first
by the way do you see why I do the
modules first why don't watch was first
than he did for him and you kind of need
it for this is dead too pitchy right
like I'll have all here if I go I don't
know what you're dividing by okay so you
need to do this alright so I am as as
was replaced before I'm gonna go to this
slide here so it's the square root of
five squared plus 2 whole square
five plus 144 I happen to know that's 13
Hey so there's my modulus let's go ahead
and work at an angle down okay so I've
got 13 side feed on equals down careful
Catholics
I've got a a vertical Pawnee horizontal
path here right society's minus 12y
right with that and at the same time
I've got 13 cause they dog and I have to
go off to the left so it's minus 5
you're right with that so far so good so
now I would say sine theta equals minus
12 or 13 no why Oh what did I say this
and really you might as well take soil
okay
because now that you've got some
regressed value right you're gonna have
to reach for your calculator obviously
to do this okay do you see why when I
see this domain
I think this rather than this have a
think about it if I said okay get your
calculator out okay calculate it if I go
cause it looks Oh where's I
by the way don't forget to switch
yourself over into radians mode you're
probably still in degrees okay you'll
know because drag will be huge okay now
when you pop in closet verse of -5 on 13
okay what angle does it give you what
angles are giving you
coz inverse of minus five on 30 versus
796 sometimes warning 1.96 1.96 okay now
there's a little bit of a problem with
1.96 1.96 where is what point is it
we're not that familiar we're not that
familiar with our our domains in that
Kobe but I've gone where I gone so so
let's think about it this way right I'll
come back to this diagram since it's
really okay yes I've gone I've gone to
the wrong place clearly I've gone to the
wrong place okay
why have I gone to the wrong place
because where do I go from here right I
know all the way here I'm just going to
try now I have to think in decimal form
okay because the radians you're going to
get when they're when they're grows like
this will be in decimal before so I've
gotten all the way around would be 3.14
in this direction so where's 1.96 it's
somewhere around here
now why have I gone up there why is it
taking me up there because because cause
we know what the cause graphic looks
like did you want remember me saying at
the top of the lesson and I'm drawing
together a whole bunch of strands so
here's cause there's cause right now
where is the first time that I'm going
to get minus 5 on 13 the answer is I'm
going to go here right there's my answer
hmm I don't want that answer though I'm
not in the second quadrant you knew from
the beginning I wasn't in the second
quadrant okay in fact I want a third
quadrant angle okay and it is there it
works okay but how do I get to that
angle how do I get to
now I've got I've got to radio to
readers I can say well I know cause is
an even function right class is an even
function so in fact I can go all the way
this way right and I can just reflect it
across so in fact according to what the
principal arguments interested in this
is a bit weird the third quadrant our
argument is not this angle this is not
the third onion because it's outside the
domain you see that it's past PI I don't
want that angle I want this angle right
I want to go at the other direction okay
so that would be negative 1.96 okay
now you could just machine your way
through that and like logic your way
through that but that's quite hard
wouldn't it maybe be a better option if
we try to use this guy right where's
this gonna go it's gonna go backwards
okay if you have your calculator then
can you give it a go and you say it's
your sine inverse why does it tell you
yeah okay so what I've done is I've gone
all the other way okay and you've got a
new angle here on the basis of this okay
you're happy with that idea
okay so what's happy da is equal to what
what num did you get negative okay so
now I've whipped around the other way
I've come around this side and gotten my
third quadrant angle which is why I want
it okay so I've got my modulus I've got
my argument I can now state it as I've
just run out of space but I'll chuck it
out here anyway
that's it in this second example is what
I got 13 outside of cos theta let's do
one let's do two decimal places that's
generally no plus I sine theta